it's a crisp Marilu Henner and derek
dancing against olympic gymnast laurie
Hernandez and bad it was faceoff week on
Dancing with the Stars where 16 year old
Olympic gymnast Laurie Hernandez had to
work extra hard to rise to the occasion
think is a very intense dance it's a lot
more dramatic a lot more passionate
it was really hard but the outfit and
the makeup really helped because they
were doing my makeup and they get a
dargol if they put them straight in my
hair I was just like oh this is very
very fast ultimately Val and Lorie beat
Derek in Marylou giving team valor
immunity from Tuesday's elimination I
was telling go struggle you know put in
that emotion so it's like I got to
pretend like I'm smelling a really good
quesadilla but still even as a
front-runner Laurie told ET she's always
nervous about the possibility of being
in jeopardy yeah that's always a thought
that's always something that you never
even want to have the chance of going
home because I love dancing I love doing
Dancing with the Stars and I've always
loved the show so I'm just glad that I
get another week to do what I love